In a shift, Amazon said it will take a team-centric approach to its return to work policy.
Andy Jassy, the company's CEO, announced that Amazon will let individual teams...
...decide how many days per week corporate employees would be expected to work in the office.
It's a departure from a previous policy which required employees...
...to return to office from at least three days a week starting in January.
Amazon, one of the largest private employers in the United States,...
...will also require its employees to be close enough to their team...
...to be able to make it to in-person meetings with a day's notice.
Exceptions will be made during a period...
...when employees will be allowed to work for up to four weeks per year...
...fully remotely from any location within the country of employment.
Amazon has taken a flexible approach to reopening like tech peer, Microsoft Corp.,...
...which said it would take a side-by-side approach to US office reopenings.